good to see everybody here we had a
great start last night with the attorney
general
and looking forward to a couple of uh
good panels this morning
this panel is on the coronavirus and the
constitution
my name is r.j pastrito i'm dean of the
van andel school of statesmanship
on campus and also a professor of
politics and i'm going to try to
moderate
this group of speakers for you we've got
about an hour and 15 minutes and each of
our speakers will
speak for 15 to 20 minutes we'll have
some perhaps discussion among them and
then turn things over
to you out in the audience for your
questions
i'm going to introduce each speaker
before uh they make the presentation
and our first speaker this morning is
robert barnes
robert barnes with high profile wins for
clients in constitutional
criminal and civil law in cases across
the country
lives in las vegas and has offices in
tennessee
wisconsin and california amongst his
more prominent clients
include the covington boys ralph nader
wesley snipes jill stein alex jones
and political parties from the greens to
the libertarians
please join me in welcoming robert
barnes
when most people think of the
constitution around the world the first
words that come to their mind are the
words that come from our first amendment
to that constitution
and core to that right is the right of
peaceable assembly
indeed that right to peaceably assembly
is essential to the other rights
in the first amendment the right of the
freedoms of press
of freedom of speech freedom of
religious expression
and the right to petition our government
for redress of grievances
our constitution which was formed in a
crisis
survived centuries of crisis indeed
there were
seven different smallpox epidemics over
the first 15 years of our young republic
never once did we suspend any of our
constitutional rights or liberties
not the right to assemble not the right
to speak not the right of religious
expression not the right to go to church
not the right to petition your
government for redress of grievances or
the right to protest
indeed we our government would survive
our constitution would survive
without those rights being suspended
through a a civil war
through world war one through world war
ii
and would survive all kinds of epidemics
including the spanish flu of 1918
including the hong kong flu of 1968 the
asian flu of 1958
through the swine flu of 1976 another
virus epidemic in 2009 and throughout
all of these we never suspended our
constitutional rights or liberties
including the core rights to peaceable
assembly
whether that was for purposes of church
or politics
or any other form of expression the
right to peaceably assemble is essential
to those other rights but it stands
alone until 2020
when across the country mayors governors
and politicians of all stripes
suspended for the first time in our
history the right to peaceable
assembly indeed it often declared
assembly itself
unlawful whether it was for the purposes
of attending
church the purposes of going to school
or for the purposes of political
organization or rallying or petitioning
for redress of
grievances or the freedom of speech how
did we get to that point
well it's important to go back to
understand the founders
and in talking about the founders to
know those founders in a broader context
than just the founding fathers that have
the statutes and the memorials and the
paintings to them
the true founding generation the true
founding fathers of the american
constitutional experiment
were as made up of boston fishermen and
back country frontiersmen and baptist
farmers
as they were merchants and bankers
indeed it was the grandsons of those
baptist farmers who helped found a small
school in southern michigan to uphold
those constitutional liberties
to extend them to abolition in support
of the abolition of slavery
to expand it to be one of the first
universities to allow african americans
and people of any race or any gender
admission to college
and that college was hillsdale college
that still stands more than a century
and a half later
in celebration of that constitution it
is in respect and recognition of that
legacy
of liberty that we inherited that was
that was bequeathed
to us by our true founding fathers that
has now
suffered its most monumental crisis
in its history some of the seeds
of the problems of our current
jurisprudence
in this area of constitutional liberty
and its suspension
date to the trilogy of infamy of cases
between 1905
and 1945 where the supreme court of the
united states
put germinated the possibilities of this
day coming where we would and in fact
legal scholars and judges alike would
openly talk about
suspending the constitution during a
quote-unquote emergency
notably the constitution of the weimar
republic of germany was celebrated as
one of the great democratic
constitutions of european history
how did it fail and end up birthing nazi
germany
because it had an emergency exception to
the constitutional liberties and rights
enclosed therein
and thus suspended them effectively
allowing the rise of nazi germany
and world war ii to soon follow
in that same context the trilogy of
infamy of decisions by the u.s supreme
court that we were supposed to have
turned our back to
have resurfaced and been resuscitated by
lawyers and litigants alike
the first one of course is jacobson
issued in 1905
where an individual is asserting that a
forced vaccination should be tested by
scientific evidence at trial before he
should be required as a condition of his
citizenship
to take it during a smallpox epidemic
outside of boston
the supreme court in the jacobson
decision effectively said that it would
defer to the executive branch
and not allow such a trial to occur that
jacobson decision was then
cited as the basis for the debuck
decision
some two decades later that is where the
u.s supreme court infamously
authorized and approved forced
sterilizations of poor women
all across the south white and black
alike in the name of
of eugenics so when you hear some
various people on the left talk about
the need to respect medical science and
our legal determination
i remember that when we deferred to
those in the white lab coats
at the very beginning of about a century
ago it was in the name of racist
eugenics
so maybe we shouldn't be so quick to
defer our political and common sense
to those in the white lab coats as if we
should live through a live milgram
experiment
of what their own druthers should be we
have a democracy for a reason
we do not defer to those in white lab
coats for that democracy
but that would not be the last decision
in the trilogy of infamy by the u.s
supreme court where it forgot
its foundational bearings where it
absconded
and abandoned its safeguarding of the
constitutional liberties that our
founders
bequeath to it that would be the
korematsu decision of 1945
which would not surprisingly also cite
the buck decision
and the jacobson decision as its legal
predicate
that would suspend the constitutional
liberties for a group of americans
simply because of the nature of their
ancestry people would be removed from
their homes
have their businesses taken from them
their jobs stripped away from them their
right of peaceable assembly suspended
for them
what we have done now in the past year
over the past six months effectively
is taking korematsu and applied it to
the entire country
in any place where the local politicians
are so willing to do
so in places like pennsylvania in
michigan new york new jersey
california large parts of the entire
country
the right of assembly has been
completely suspended the right of speech
completely suspended the right of
religious expression
completely suspended in my home state of
nevada if you want to form a church you
need to go to
a casino to do so if you want to be able
to have meaningful congregation and
participation
as my mom used to say when i was a kid
when i didn't want to go to church on a
particular sunday morning
and wanted to sleep in instead you
should not forsake the fellowship of
your fellow believers
yet we are being forced to do so all
across the country and in places like
las vegas if you want to go to church
you should just operate it inside of
either caesars or
the wind and there you can rent a
convention center room and actually form
church that's the peculiar logic our u.s
supreme court adopted this past summer
though over four notable dissents but
that ignoble history of our recent
history
against the noble history of our
constitutional liberty in the centuries
before
has finally met a resistance in the form
of a young
41 year old federal district court judge
in the western district of pennsylvania
appointed by president trump this week
he issued a decision
striking down the lockdown orders of the
pennsylvania governor
as unconstitutional in violation of that
right of peaceable assembly
in violation of that right of free
speech of free press and pre-religious
expression
not only that he recognized it as a
violation of both substantive and
procedural due process
under the 14th amendment to the u.s
constitution for businesses
and those who would have it as he noted
what led to a position where the
judiciary was
consciously and publicly stating it was
going to susp
to completely suspend its role as an
independent check
on either the legislative or executive
branch in the name of a crisis
there is no emergency exception in the
u.s constitution
though president uh first our first
president george washington was
intimately aware of the problems of
smallpox
indeed as uh mr berenson can comment
upon
what the one of the very first
inclinations of
then general george washington was herd
immunity
should be the solution for dealing with
viruses he inoculated
his soldiers with very small doses
hopefully not enough to cause them to
incur the full wrath of smallpox which
had a 30
fatality rate which is far far higher
than the one that covet 19 presents to
us
he understood that and yet he didn't
have an emergency exception to the u.s
constitution
he didn't suspend our constitution when
smallpox epidemics
raged across america in his first two
terms as president of the united states
and yet somehow many of our governors
suddenly thought that the word governor
must have meant something from the
colonial days and they could start
issuing royal edicts
as if they were the colonial governors
that we overthrew in our constitutional
republic
notably this judge the judge stickman
from western district of pennsylvania a
man from steel town from pittsburgh
someone as attorney general barr was
talking about last night
having more judges having more
prosecutors rooted in the local
community
and understanding and responsive to the
democracy that is supposed to govern us
is critical and essential to the
functioning of justice
in our modern age and he fits that
precise description
what he required was a full trial and a
complete record
and where finally the evidence would be
tested
what is the evidence in support of these
lockdown provisions what is the counter
evidence what does this evidence look
like
under cross-examination and what we
found was there was almost no evidence
at all
what the judge found was that the this
was more like in his own words
a theoretical white paper where you
basically have the white lab coat
crowd doing a live milgram experiment on
its population
for those who don't know the milgram
experiments is where
someone would be brought in just someone
with a white lab coat they knew nothing
else about them
would tell them would you please shock
this person in the other room
and and they would tell them to keep
turning up the shocks
if their answers were quote unquote
wrong they had no reason to believe that
the shocks were morally or legally
justified
some would express concern about their
own legal liability
but as long as the person in the white
lab code kept telling him to do it they
kept doing it and doing it and doing it
and over half of the populace would do
so
we're seeing that now in whether to wear
masks or not wear masks whether to
social distance when to social distance
how to social distance
whether to have a lockdown or not a
lockdown how we can have as this judge
noted a
sort of a corporate woke virus that
somehow knew the difference between
church and walmart or church in a casino
that it knew that if it saw you know
caesars or bellagio
it it couldn't go in there that was
dangerous but if it saw a small baptist
church it would raid immediately
in the same way if it was going through
any kind of community if it's all
walmart or a costco it knew that's an
inappropriate
not a proper place to go but if it's a
small and pop shop they had to invade
there right away
yet these were the rules that were being
laid down by our governors and mayors
all across the country walmart's safe
mom and pop not
casino safe church not these rules were
rules that simply confounded
not only common sense but constitutional
sense but unfortunately
until this week our federal courts had
turned a blind eye to it many of our
state courts
had turned a blind eye to it not all but
most
it took the bravery of a young trump 41
trump appointee 41 year old
federal jurist to point out the obvious
that when he looked at the evidence he
said there was no evidence for the
lockdowns
he pointed out that in our entire
american history we had
never ever locked down we had never
suspended all constitutional rights and
liberties
for any period of time anywhere for all
the local population
for any reason he pointed out that in
fact the evidence
that could be produced by the state was
weak to non-existent
while the counter evidence was often
overwhelming that there was serious
doubts about whether
any of these quote unquote mitigation
measures mitigated
anything at all it was on that basis
that he rejected their decision
he noted their logic was internally
contradictory externally contradictory
to existing evidence
it didn't even make sense within its own
rules and it was often nothing more than
a theoretical white paper
being imposed on the population of
pennsylvania to their great expense
and detriment he noted that in fact
there was no evidence that public
gatherings of the kind that they were
trying to be suspended or prohibited
or assembly that was being restricted
and listed as unlawful
had caused any form of super spreading
event that led to any
mass deaths of any kind indeed the only
kind that that had been was the nursing
home policies the governors
of pennsylvania and michigan and new
york and new jersey had done
where they forced people who are sick
and elderly back into the nursing home
to infect the rest
but it wasn't lawful assembly that posed
any degree of health threat by any of
the documented or detailed evidence
yet it had been suspended throughout
pennsylvania not for days not for weeks
as originally promised
but for months and months and months
with no end
as he pointed out a quarantine is
supposed to be sick specific
the person who has you have clear and
convincing evidence that a particular
person
presents an imminent risk to other
people within the community
fits the same constitutional due process
standards we've had for involuntary
institutionalization
of the mentally ill the same standards
apply to the medically ill
these lockdown orders were not
consistent with any form of public
quarantine
and the state would admit during the
proceedings that in fact it could not
meet the definition statutorily
or as constitutionally permitted of a
quarantine
instead they came to a different
defense what was their defense there's
no fundamental right to make a living
period that was their argument
and they expected a court to accept it
adopt it and impose it on the rest of us
that no american no pennsylvanian in
that case
had any fundamental right to make a
living to support their family to
support themselves
apparently the words pursuit of
happiness no longer appeared in the new
declaration of independence as written
by the
pennsylvania governor indeed despite the
fact that the right to make a living was
fundamental and established as such from
the very inception of our constitution
and
repeated as such going back to decisions
from the 1800s
somehow that was completely ignored and
wished to be obliterated
by the new democratic regime in the
state of pennsylvania
they admitted that their definition of
quote unquote life-sustaining businesses
which were given an exception and an
exemption from the
gathering provisions and the assembly
provisions had no definition at all
there was no standard for it there was
no policy behind it it changed day to
day week to week
it was like something the stasi or the
polar borough would have come up with
indeed as the court noted it failed to
meet even the most basic constitutional
standards of governmental action
and it was for that reason that the
court determined and rejected
what the governor of pennsylvania said
said there is indeed a right to make a
living there is indeed a right to
assemble and that these rights cannot be
suspended
in the name of an emergency they cannot
be declared invalid
unilaterally by the actions of the
executive branch of any government
and he concluded in this way and it's a
conclusion we should all remember
as we move forward in the cases that i
and other lawyers will be bringing
across the country in the name of this
case
and this is here is his final quote the
liberties protected by the constitution
are not
fair-weather freedoms the constitution
cannot accept a quote
new normal where the basic liberties of
the people
can be subordinated to open-ended
emergency mitigation measures
the constitution sets lines and these
actions cross those lines
let it be so across the country thank
[Music]
you
with apologies to our other two speakers
i'm not sure how you follow that
but i'm sure they'll they will do very
well and our next speaker is alex
berenson
he graduated from yale university in
1994
with degrees in history and economics he
was a reporter at the denver post
and then at thestreet.com in 1999
he joined the new york times and at the
times
he covered everything from the drug
industry to hurricane katrina
and then he served two stints as a
correspondent in iraq
an experience led him to write the
faithful spy
which was his debut novel he has now
written
12 john wells novels and two non-fiction
books
the number and tell your children please
welcome
alex berenson
so um as you might
guess from that pedigree i uh
didn't really expect that i would be
spending all my time speaking to
conservative groups and audiences
for the last couple of years but here i
am um
and uh and i've been forced into your
hands
um and the reason i've been forced into
your hands is that the left
does not want to talk about data
and science as much as they say they do
and certainly certainly when it comes to
coronavirus they don't
you know science science is not
dr anthony fauci saying this is what
science is
and it you know it's not it's not
somebody saying we all follow the
science you must follow the sciences my
mother who's an inveterate
and msnbc watcher says to me i just
follow the science and i say
you have no idea what the data says and
what science is at its heart is
examining
data sets clinical trials
coming up with theories that fit those
that fit the data you have trying to
test those theories
trying to reproduce them people being
able to reproduce
the data independently whether it comes
out of a lab or whether it's real world
data
it's not magic and it is something we
can debate
and discuss and that's what we should be
doing but
but the but the left and the media have
uh have sort of grabbed the reins of
this
in a way that that i never would have
expected and they refuse to debate
anything they don't like um you know i
have a
i have a couple hundred thousand
followers on twitter which is sort of my
main
outlet to to to get some of these points
across
and i have been blocked by i don't know
how many people
um who who i've never even heard of
media types
um what i call blue checks who have lots
of followers who just
don't who who are so opposed to hearing
anything they don't want to hear
that they've preemptively blocked me
this is this is not
how discourse moves forward
um so so so just to talk a little bit
about
the failure which is actually both a
failure and a crushing success of
expertise because
the public health establishment has
really crushed any debate
the first signal failure came
with the failure of the models in uh in
march and april
so so there were predictions made that
the hospitals
in new york and elsewhere would be
overrun and those predictions
weren't made out of nowhere okay they
weren't made out of thin air
the theory was and this is true it takes
it takes a week to two weeks after
you're infected with the coronavirus
to uh to become sick enough to be
hospitalized
depending on you know your age and your
comorbidities and
uh the viral load that you got you know
and obviously most people who are
infected with the coronavirus never even
know it that now
appears to be clear based on um based on
the serology test showing that many many
more people are infected
um then we have active uh then we know
we're actively infected
that suggests that many people were
infected and recovered without even
knowing it
but some group of people who are
infected will become sick
and it takes a little while for them to
become sick it takes a little while
longer for them to be hospitalized
and then you know for that tiny fraction
of people who are unfortunate enough to
wind up in the icu or ultimately to die
that takes a little while longer too
so so in in mid to late march
as the numbers were increasing in new
york city especially
the the fear of epidemiologists was
those numbers show what happened on for
example
the the uh the number of
hospitalizations on march 22nd
shows the number of infections on march
10th but there was no lockdown on march
10th
so if the virus is spreading quickly
through uh through the new york city
population
by the time we actually lock down which
was march 22nd
those 12 days there would have been a
huge huge
rise in infections and that rise would
have led to a
an overwhelming rise in hospitalizations
in the next 12 days
that was the fear okay this is that's
really where
all of this comes from that fear
that didn't happen the models failed in
late march and they failed in april
they failed basically in real time you
could see it happening
this is how i first got attention
because i just pointed out
here's what the models say should be
happening they say that 50 to 70
000 people in new york state should be
hospitalized and the real number's about
15 000 and it's not going up very fast
that meant basically that the lockdowns
had failed
because follow me here
if if the lockdowns worked there would
have been this huge spike in cases
and then that spike would have dropped
off very very rapidly as the lockdowns
kicked in and new infections stopped
instead there was a
there was a much shorter spike of a
lower spike that didn't reach the levels
that were predicted and it went on and
on and on
suggesting that the lockdowns hadn't
really been effective and that the virus
wasn't as dangerous as we thought far
fewer people were being hospitalized
that all by itself should have led to a
huge reconsideration of what we were
doing it did nothing of the sort
and six months later the same people who
wanted those lockdowns
in march are calling for a second wave
of lockdowns
despite six months of real-world
evidence that a they don't work
b the hospital system can manage even in
places like houston
and phoenix and miami that were hit this
summer
there was no hospital crisis there were
crowded hospitals yes
there was no hospital crisis that should
call into question
everything that we thought we were doing
in march
and and to and to go back further
this panic was not just predictable it
was predicted
the sum of the same experts who now are
desperate
for masks and lockdowns and other public
health interventions
before march warned about this they said
there is a real chance we're going to
panic at the wrong time
that we're going to impose all these
incredibly expensive
and complicated and society destroying
and school destroying and economy
destroying
public health measures that don't really
work
we need to be careful about that and
then when march came and
and you can see some of these people
saying this in january and february
okay as the chinese were were locking
down in wuhan and hubei
they said we don't think this is a great
idea
and in march that all flipped
the public health establishment went
crazy and it has not been able to pull
itself
out of the ditch and we are stuck
fighting them
with facts and data that they don't want
to hear but because
so much of the media outside the
conservative media
won't even talk about this stuff it's
very hard to have an honest debate
or discussion and
and so so here we are now
six months later fighting about masks
and about
test and trace and isolate and about
a vaccine and whether that should be
mandatory when it comes
meanwhile in the real world the virus
has killed almost nobody under
60 and certainly almost nobody under 60
who wasn't
quite ill i'm not saying they're not
cases okay but
if you look at at
who actually gets sick and dies from the
coronavirus
it is it is overwhelmingly people who
are who are
either extremely elderly or extremely
sick
or both that's why forty to fifty
percent of all the deaths from the
coronavirus occur
in people in nursing homes and long-term
care facilities and by the way that does
not mean
it's not real it does not mean we
shouldn't try
to help people who are at risk it does
not mean those deaths don't matter
all the things people like to say about
me i don't think any of those things
what it means is that we have to balance
society's
our response our our responsibility to
all of society
and especially to children to our
responsibility
to the people who are in many cases at
death's door
okay there's something you know when
you're when you're doing bookkeeping
you have to look at assets and
liabilities you have to look at both
sides of the ledger
this can't just be about trying to
protect
a few hundred thousand people who are
very sick anyway it has to be about all
of society especially since we have next
to no evidence
that any of those measures that we
undertook did any good
i mean that's the icing on the cake on
this is that we don't even know
that anything we did worked but we
have this overwhelming desire to do
something
to do anything i mean i've sort of the
older i get the more i understand that
what's so intelligence is important but
so much less important than intelligence
or so much more important than
intelligence
is the ability to stay cool and calm
under pressure
and in dangerous times okay give me give
me the guy or the woman
who can stay cool under fire okay
we panicked we had an overwhelming
desire
to do something even though there was no
evidence
for what we were doing the simplest
public health measures
are the ones that work stay home if
you're sick
wash your hands don't spit on the ground
we used to spit on the ground all the
time in this country there were
spittoons everywhere we don't do that
anymore
i mean really like you know sneeze into
your elbow
that's about it okay that's about all
that we know works
everything else is questionable to a
greater or lesser extent
and masks are i would say the evidence
is near zero
that anything but a properly fitted n95
mask
does much of anything okay and there's
evidence that masks
actually may not may be
counterproductive because they
discourage people from doing these other
things
and to the extent masks make a
difference they probably make a
difference as a signaling mechanism in
other words
if we tell sick people to wear masks it
signals to other people
that they're sick and they and then
people give them space
doesn't mean you're you're uh you know
you're you're being negative about them
it just means you're giving them some
space that they're sick but guess what
when you have universal masks
that signaling mechanism disappears it
destroys the only
benefit of the mask so
so we are stuck and and
the reality of the situation and what
the media and public health
establishments are saying
are diverging more and more and people
are you know people are
getting fed up and they're you know and
they're sort of throwing you know
we're all not all of us but a lot of us
i think are living in what
to some extent must have felt like in
the soviet union about 1982
when it was clear that you know that
everything had failed
and that you know you couldn't get any
fresh fruit in your your car if you were
lucky to have one
you know the engine fell out half the
time but you had to you know but
everybody said that glorious socialist
state was going on you know
we are being told over and over again
that this is the worst
you know epidemic since the spanish flu
when
most people don't know anyone who's died
from this
and certainly most people don't know
anyone who's died from this and i mean
when i say most i mean almost all i've
i've conducted a
survey about this and you know and
there's been you know there's been
other surveys conducted about it uh you
know somewhere between eighty percent
america of and ninety percent of
americans don't know anyone who's died
from covid
and most of the you know the people who
who and you you define no as broadly
okay so bro you know
not not a family member but just
somebody you might have heard of who's a
friend or something like that so
so most people don't know anyone who's
died from covid and the people who know
someone who's died from covet
those those deaths overwhelmingly again
are
you know people who are older and quite
ill so the reality
of the fact that this isn't that
dangerous to most
people to almost all people and what
we're being told is the gap is getting
too
far for anybody to accept
anymore and so people are returning to
their lives but they're doing it
in the face of government dictats that
are supposed to
you know that that i guess we're all
sort of saying are not going to be
enforced so you know
kamala harris said uh you know there'll
be a mask mandate but we won't enforce
it so what does that mean
i mean really like is it just a strongly
worded suggestion
like i i don't know so
so so you know that doesn't breed
respect for government or the law or
or you know or or science or anything
else it's a bad way to live
when what you see happening and what
you're being forced to pretend in public
is happening are not the same thing
and i hope we can stop that so
so i you know i i i could i could talk
for
an hour i mean this is to some extent
this is like the old aaa stuff
five minutes is too much and an hour
would not be enough um
but uh um but i but i wanna sort of i
wanna sort of leave you with one thing
it's very
it's very easy to say this is all about
trump okay that you know the media hates
trump or
unfortunately there's a lot of people in
academia including in the physical
sciences who hate trump
if you know if trump is not if trump is
not reelected this will go away
the evidence on the ground is that is
not true okay new zealand and australia
are both led by progressives they have
extremely hard lockdowns
okay and and joe biden has indicated
that he you know he will
he will follow the science the same
signs my mother follows on msnbc
um and uh and
and you know basically continue masks
and you know
impose another lockdown at the drop of a
hat so it's easy to blame this on sort
of the
hatred for trump but there are but but
that misunderstands what's happening
here
okay to some extent we are doing this
because we can what do i mean i mean we
now have the bandwidth
that most white-collar workers can stay
home
okay and we can run schools in this
horrible way but theoretically schools
can function at a distance
even five years ago that would not have
been possible
okay much less 10 or 15 or 20 years ago
so we have the bandwidth
to enable us to exist remotely or you
know for the
for the people who have the most money
and the most political power in society
to exist remotely and we have a bunch of
companies
that are benefiting massively from this
tech companies
i i don't you know if any of you are
fortunate enough to own amazon or apple
those stocks have done really well this
year the market is not stupid
okay so so we have the ability to do
this and we have an interest group
and ultra interest group by the way
which is now actively censoring people
like me
and bob um that that is encouraging this
that's
a and that's not going away okay that
that
that force is only becoming more
powerful
b we in in 1960 i couldn't believe this
when i
when i looked it up i knew that the
number would be low but i didn't know
how low it would be
in 1960 the united states spent 27
billion dollars
on medical care okay even adjusted for
inflation was 230 billion
that was about five percent of gdp
healthcare is now
20 of gdp it is almost 4 trillion
it is a massive and massively powerful
sector in the economy
and and we are spending we're spending
almost a billion dollars a week on
tests for covet alone okay patients are
a
throughput when you run the health a
healthcare company
you need patients i'm not saying that
this was created for that but what i am
saying is that the power
the power to to supercharge
this rather modest epidemic into
something that has shut down society
has been driven by two incredibly
powerful sectors of the economy
both of which benefit and those
trends are only going to get worse
tech is only getting more powerful and
and healthcare is only becoming larger
as a part of the economy
so we're kind of lucky this time this
one wasn't bad enough
to actually be what they wanted it i'm
not going to say wanted that's the wrong
word
it wasn't bad enough to actually force
us to shut down
society in the way that some people i
don't want to say hope but in some in
the way some people encourage
us to do but there will be another flu
there will be an h1n1
there will be something else and if the
and if the infection fatality rate on
that
is half a percent let's say instead of
you know
one two tenths of a percent or three
tenths of a percent or whatever this one
is whatever
fraction this is the pressure will be
even more overwhelming to force us back
into lockdown
back remotely the experts are not going
away
these trends are not going away and that
is why it is so
important to fight this battle and to
talk
about what the data and the science
actually say
and so
[Applause]
and so so we just have to keep doing it
um
because because otherwise we're never
going to get out of this
thank you and our uh third panelist is
john hinderaker
john spent 41 years as a litigator in
minnesota
upon his retirement from the legal
profession
at the end of 2015 he became
president of the center for the american
experiment
which is minnesota's conservative policy
organization
in addition to his legal and think tank
work
john as many of you know is a long time
commentator and activist
he founded the website powerline in 2002
and he has been a prominent voice on the
internet and
elsewhere since that time
he has appeared as a commentator on
almost all major networks he's a
frequent
guest and guest host on national and
local radio
programs and he's lectured at many
colleges
and universities although i don't know
if he's been invited recently
i should i had to ask about that when i
saw that in his
bio so please join me in welcoming john
hinderegger
thank you very much copa 19 is a medical
event to be sure but
arguably it is just as much a political
event
and i'm afraid that what it says about
the current state of our politics
is not positive when news of the wuhan
flu
first arose the immediate reaction from
almost everyone was
what is the government in particular the
federal government
going to do about it we've seen endless
references to government
president trump and the governors
handling the coronavirus
and heard about things government is
doing to fight
the virus now this is a very different
reaction from past epidemics
in 1968 the hong kong flu killed a
million people worldwide and more than a
hundred thousand in the us when our
population was
much smaller i was a college student in
1968 and i have no memory
of a virus going around at that time
schools and businesses were not shut
down
and no one imagined that it was the
government's job to
handle or to fight that virus it wasn't
even much of a news story
it has been pointed out that the
woodstock music festival was held while
the hong kong flu epidemic was still
going on in 1969
and that is true to say that there was
no
social distancing at woodstock would be
an understatement but at the time no one
thought anything about it
but that was a different era today most
americans
seem to have lost the idea that our
government is supposed to be limited
especially the federal government
and that government is not omnicompetent
in 1976 a democratic politician
criticized hubert humphrey
he said quote i think the thing that's
most wrong with hubert humphrey is that
he is not
cognizant of the limited finite ability
government has to deal with people's
problems
who said that joe biden
we've come a long way since then in our
expectations of government and not
in a good direction now the second
striking fact about the politics of
coronavirus has been the willingness of
americans to put up with and for the
most part to endorse
fundamental restrictions on their
freedoms in state after state we have
seen governors issue
stay home orders that literally directed
americans to stay in their houses
except to the limited extent they were
permitted to go out
by the government would prior
generations of americans have submitted
meekly to orders to stay in their homes
close their businesses
and so forth i don't think so
and the shutdowns in nearly every state
have dragged on for months
long after the original flatten the
curve rationale has
been forgotten the shutdowns are
starting to feel permanent and by the
way do you even
remember that when there was an explicit
rationale
for the shutdowns this is just brief
it's just temporary we're just trying to
flatten the curve
same number of infections just spread
over a longer period of time
that whole rationale has now completely
gone by the boards
most recently mask mandates have been
added and almost all americans have
dutifully donned masks even though we
have no idea
whether they're actually doing any good
so why has there been relatively little
political pushback against the shutdown
orders i think there are several reasons
first the emergency posed by covid19 has
been grossly exaggerated
to an extent that i think can only be
seen as deliberate
remember that early on government at all
levels purported to be acting in
reliance on models
that predicted millions of deaths in the
united states
my own state minnesota created its own
model that predicted more than
70 000 deaths in our state without a
shutdown
and 50 000 deaths with a shutdown
we learned later that the model had been
created by a few graduate students over
a weekend
but by then it was too late
all of these models turned out to be
ridiculously off target
but instead instead of saying oops never
mind
governors simply kept in place the
lockdown orders that originally had been
predicated on them
now i think the centers for disease
control has also contributed to the
public's exaggerated sense of the
virus's danger in a number of ways
one of the most important was the
guidance it gave to the states to count
deaths as coveted fatalities even if
covid was not
the immediate cause of death the
clearest statement i've seen of this
practice came from the head of the
illinois department of health who was
giving a press conference and she said
when we classify a death as covet
related we are not saying that it was
the cause of death
a person could be dying of cancer and be
in hospice care but if he happens
also to have coveted we will count that
death in the coveted column when we do
that
we are not saying it was the cause of
death
that's a very very important point i
think and the federal government has
compounded the problem by offering
cash incentives to hospitals to classify
patients as quoted related and deaths is
covered related
under the cares act medicare
reimbursements are increased by
20 percent if there is a covet diagnosis
so we are literally paying to maximize
the number of reported covet patients
and covet deaths what all this means is
that every headline that you have seen
trumpeting the claim that the wuhan
virus has killed 180 000 people in the
u.s
or whatever that number or wherever that
number stands at the moment
every headline you've seen trumpeting
that claim is
wrong what the actual number of deaths
caused by covet is no one knows
but the scare campaign mounted by the
media has given the public an impression
of covid's lethality
far beyond anything promoted by cdc
you may have heard about the
international survey that was done by
kext
cnc that firm asked the question
how many people in your country have
died from coronavirus
as a percentage of the population
in the u.s the average response was
nine percent now nine percent think of
that
that would be around 30 million people
which is worse by
two orders of magnitude than the most
pessimistic
current estimates now how did the
american people
come to be so grotesquely misinformed
i i can't read the minds of the people
at the cdc
the the modelers various public health
officials
reporters and editors and so forth but i
think it is a plausible guess
that the sustained overhyping of covid
was a deliberate attempt on the part of
some of these people
to create an issue that might cost
president trump a second term
i think we can infer that from the fact
that hysterical exaggerations of kovid's
lethality
have been coupled with constant attacks
on the president's actions in response
to the virus
many of which attacks have been
completely groundless and even
even nonsensical so
so the creation of an overhyped
emergency certainly helps to explain why
americans have been so accepting of
limitations on their freedom
but i think there's more to the story
than that i think another reason why the
shutdowns have not been more politically
costly to governors is because many
people don't mind them much
to a great extent what we have seen has
been shut down
theater small businesses are closed
but as alex pointed out target and
walmart are open
meat packing plants have frequently been
hotbeds of coveted infection but they
haven't been closed down
other than briefly in an individual case
in response to
a particular outbreak why is that
well it's because we need meat in the
grocery stores
without meat in the grocery stores
voters would get restless
and i think the ultimate proof of the
shutdown's basic
lack of seriousness is that while it is
deemed
too dangerous in many states to go to
church
total wine stores are open everywhere
now
if you can catch a virus in a small
business a restaurant or a church pew
you obviously can also catch it in a
target store or a
total wine store but governors knew
that if they closed the liquor stores
there would be pitchforks in the street
and so in every state the liquor stores
have stayed open
so we've had a situation where governors
have gained politically
by proclaiming a grave emergency and
supposedly taking strong action to
combat it
while at the same time the shutdowns
have been so full of exceptions that
they didn't seriously inconvenience most
people
unless of course their jobs or their
small businesses
were impacted as a matter of fact you
can't find any apparent correlation
between the severity of a shutdown order
in a given state
and the number of covered cases or
hospitalizations or deaths
in that state there doesn't seem to be
any correlation at all
and i think if we drill a little deeper
we find another political element
the covet shutdowns devastated small
businesses putting many thousands into
bankruptcy
but big business and alex mentioned this
too big business
has largely prospered thus for example
target walmart costco
home depot amazon and apple
have all achieved record share prices
during the covet epidemic this is one
reason why the stock market has been so
weirdly buoyant after the initial shock
in the spring
so big business is largely happy with
the shutdowns well who else hasn't been
bothered much
by the by the lockdowns public employees
i assume there are exceptions here and
there but generally public employees
have simply continued to draw their
paychecks in some cases to get raises
whether they were actually performing
any any work or not
that doesn't give them much to complain
about who else hasn't minded the
pandemic
urban knowledge workers these folks for
the most part are able to do their work
at home and on
zoom and many of them prefer it that way
for many
urban knowledge workers the shutdowns
have mostly been a plus
now ask yourselves what are the key
constituencies of the democratic party
they are big business not all of it but
most of it
public sector employees and urban
knowledge workers
and as it happens those are the
constituencies that have generally been
least injured
by the shutdowns now on the other hand
what are the key constituencies of the
republican party small business in rural
america
the very elements of our society that
have been devastated
by the covet shutdowns is that a
coincidence
i don't know but i'm sure that the
democratic governors who
generally have imposed the most drastic
shutdowns
were well aware that their own
supporters were less likely to be
damaged
and to protest than the other parties
it has been widely reported that
republicans tend to oppose
lockdown orders more than democrats and
are more likely to resist
mass mandates and social distancing
orders
as well why is that well i think it is
partly for the reason i just said on the
average republicans are probably being
hurt by the shutdowns more than
democrats
but there are other reasons too in
general
democrats trust government more than
republicans
and republicans are more concerned with
personal freedom
we see these tendencies across the whole
spectrum
of political issues
today the general lack of serious
resistance to the covet shutdown
suggests that in the perennial tension
between security and freedom
freedom is losing out many have also
said that republicans worry less about
kova the democrats because they are not
as risk-averse
and there's probably some truth to that
too obviously risk aversion is related
to how one values freedom and whether
one looks to government for safety
at all costs but i would point out
that the democrats aversion to covert
risk
is highly selective i've seen little
aversion
to the risk of other health conditions
resulting from foregone checkups and
medical care
or the risk to the mental health of many
vulnerable people who are deprived of
normal
social interaction or the risk to the to
the livelihoods and in the lifetime of
investment
of many thousands of small business
owners whose dreams have gone up in
smoke
i've seen no risk aversion or little
risk aversion to those risks
on the part of democrats and that makes
me wonder
whether those who seem to be cheering on
quote 19 at times
are more interested in bringing down
president trump
than anything else
finally these days you can't talk about
politics without turning to the polls
so i want to review briefly what the
polls have been telling us over the last
five months
and the numbers i'm going to give you
come from polling done by a consortium
that includes harvard northwestern a
couple of
other institutions and they have polled
all 50 states
starting in april and continuing to the
present
time so it's a nice consistent data set
well looking at those numbers from the
beginning the respondents have not rated
president trump highly on his response
to covin
he started at 42 in april declined
steadily to a low of 32 percent
in july and rebounded slightly to 34
percent in august i think it is fair to
say that the covet epidemic epidemic has
served the purpose that was intended in
some quarters
and that is the presidential election
has gone from being in my opinion a near
sure thing for president trump at the
beginning of 2020
to being today a toss-up
now the governors have consistently been
rated more highly on their covert
performances than
president trump in fact as of april
every single governor had a higher
covert rating
than the president every single governor
now that has shifted
in august president trump had a higher
covet approval rating than
10 governors interestingly all 10 of
those
low-rated governors are republicans
why would that be well i suspect that at
least one part of the reason
is because republicans at all levels of
government
get worse press coverage than democrats
and i suspect that that's mostly what
we're seeing there
now all of that said the governor's
approval in general has been slipping
in late april the governor's
collectively had a 63 percent
approval rating on covid that has been
declining and it stands at 48
down 15 points in august now one hopes
that that reflects growing impatience
with the shutdowns the mask mandates
and so on there are a few bright spots
in the polling for example governor
newsom of california has gone from
70 percent coveted approval in april
to 47 percent in august
but in general the polling suggests that
people
tend to approve the most the governors
that have gone the farthest
in limiting their freedom so
i will wrap up by noting that the
political gain games
surrounding covet 19 are far from over
the trump administration is rushing to
get a vaccine tested approved and
distributed by the end of the year
so now we see the spectacle of joe biden
and kamala harris turning anti-vaxxer
and saying that they won't take or they
may not take
any vaccine that is produced by the
trump administration
so the politicizing of the wuhan virus
is going to continue until november
and well beyond thank you very much
okay thank you to each of our presenters
uh we're going to
uh present them with some questions and
we're going to go to the audience in a
moment but i
wanted to start with one of of my own
and this really could be
taken i think by any of our panelists
and
my question is what what can be done
if anything about the censorship
on the of of the relevant
scientific data maybe
mr berenson's most relevant to your
presentation in other words
if we ever want to be in a position to
have any kind of
public airing or serious public debate
uh the centers the censorship and the
major the private
tech platforms facebook twitter and
others
it seems if we can't if we can't lick
that problem
we'll never have any serious public
debate
and so i wonder if uh if you or any of
the other panelists have any
thoughts on that
i mean that that strikes me as almost a
more legal question
what do you know whether whether i mean
these are private companies so
i mean i mean the problem is the
monopolization of the public square
by private monopolies which there was a
time when you know company towns back in
the 1920s 1930s
decided that their solution to things
like
mining organizers and labor unions was
well
if we just own the whole town then they
can't organize anymore and they can't
assemble anymore
and the answer of the courts in a
separate case later on
was the u.s supreme court at the time
was if you choose to privately
monopolize
part of the public square then you are
as bound by the first amendment as any
public entity
because it's a combination of a monopoly
plus part of the public square
that decision was followed up in a case
called pruneyard by the state of
california which applied it to private
malls
which said that the public space within
a private mall was really a public
square
the mall had chosen to monopolize
ownership and control of that space
so as a condition of its continued
existence it would be required to have
first amendment application
logically given that almost all of the
big tech companies are based in
california you might think
that they would apply the same print
yard principles to the
private monopolization of the public
square particularly by companies that
came to monopolize the public square
by lying to the american people twitter
promised to be
the free speech wing of the free speech
party you can ask
alex how that's working out uh you can
go to youtube it's even worse google's
even worse
facebook even worse the degree of
censorship to where now
doctors including doctors advising
president trump
are having their medical reports taken
down from youtube
because it disagrees with the world
health organization which by that
standard everything the world health
organization
publishes should be brought down because
they've disagreed with themselves
particularly about the wuhan virus it
was after all the world health
organization that told everybody back in
january
don't worry there's no human to human
transmission with covet
so the the only unfortunately what the
courts have done
it's even more egregious in many
contexts than what they've done in the
covid responses
is they have chosen to say these are
private companies and interpreted
section 230
of the communications decency act to
give them broad scale immunity
they interpret it as like a political
license
for these companies to do whatever they
want and they say it preempts all state
law
and they refuse to apply any constraint
to these companies the idea that some of
us had we recommended to
senator hawley several years ago and
senator hawley's now proposed
legislation
and i think the only remedy is going to
come from congress it has because the
courts are functionally closed until
congress sends a different message is a
is to give a carrot and a stick
if they want immunity as a publisher for
things other people
publish on their platforms then they
have to abide by first amendment
restrictions
and if they will abide by that there's a
big body of first amendment law that
precludes pornography precludes
child pornography precludes harassment
precludes stalking
precludes obscenity it's not within its
uh contours of its protections
that if they want the special immunity
that section 230 provides
they have that's the carrot then the
stick is they have to abide by the first
amendment restrictions
once they reach a certain economic
dominance place those once they have the
equivalent of a monopoly
over any part of the public square more
than 75 percent control
is how the anti-trust laws tend to
define it which is what twitter facebook
and google currently have
uh and google has it in the youtube
space through visual and then has it in
the search base through
the internet then they have to abide by
first amendment restrictions
and they almost every of one of those
big tech companies will take that trade
off
so that's the legislative solution that
i think is the only solution because
until then
they will do whatever they want and
they've exposed that very badly in this
context
i think john wants to i think there's
one one other possibility these big tech
platforms i think are monopolies
currently monopoly law doesn't really
really address any evil of monopoly
other than high prices
but that's not inherent i i think that
the
law of monopoly could be developed in
such a way that there are
other uh wrongful conduct that
monopolists can engage in that could be
redressed in the courts
and impinging on freedom of speech of
speech could be one of those
those forms of of monopoly misuse
so i think that is a legal development
that could potentially come out of the
supreme court if we ever had a
conservative supreme court
um can i just add uh
i i think this is a very very dangerous
trend um
on a couple of levels i think i think
when honest debate and discussion are
squelched
uh it drives people to believe in
conspiracy theory
real conspiracy theory it will drive you
know
people to 4chan and 8chan you know it
will
it will i mean i don't know very much
about q anon
okay but obviously that has been
becoming more popular
that sort of set of conspiracy doctrines
and
and and when you when you don't allow
people to have honest discussion
either in conventional or social media
they will tend to believe the worst
um and you can combine that with
something that has actually that i know
has happened
so so you know for several months people
were trying to get me to talk about
pcr testing and decay stomach and and i
didn't really
chase it because i had a few other
things to chase
and because i sort of thought there's no
way that you know that the testing
companies have their thumb
on the scale uh to you know to make the
numbers look
much worse than they are the numbers of
reported covet infections
um and and it actually fell to the new
york times to report a story that ran on
page a6
although it should have been on a1 and
it should have been followed up by every
newspaper and good investigative
reporter in the country which is
we we are running our pcr tests
which is how most cases of the virus are
diagnosed in the united states and
around the world
in a way that hugely overstates the
number of people who are actively
infected at any time
okay that's that's just a scientific
fact and you can find scientists
you know for places like the european
cdc discussing this
there's a complicated technical
explanation for what's going on here
but the short answer is we are
overstating the number of tests or the
number of active infected
infections hugely which is probably also
causing us to overstate the number of
deaths substantially
um so so i didn't really think that that
was possible and i didn't chase it
okay just as until the last couple of
weeks i haven't really been paying that
much attention
to this idea that you know where did the
virus come from did it actually escape a
chinese lab
and what experiments might have been
being run those stories
are real and worth chasing even if we
don't know exactly where they're going
to go
and major media outlets like the new
york times
don't seem to be pursuing them you know
they're not pursuing them
i i can only think because when
president trump
calls it the china virus people you know
people in the media don't like it
so they don't want to pursue where sars
cove too i don't call it the china virus
because that's not its name i call it
stars cove 2
where it might actually have come from
it doesn't matter what we call it
it matters whether it escaped from a
chinese lab and whether the chinese were
experimenting with it before it escaped
and that's what we should be looking at
but when major media outlets won't
they drive people to conspiracy theory
and that's dangerous for all of us
all right very good
so i believe we have uh roving
microphone holders for those of you in
the audience who
would like to ask a question
okay i'm sorry the lights are right in
my eyes so i'm having trouble seeing
folks please
okay yeah well if alex following up on
your comment
uh let's say that pfizer had developed a
virus and it got out of their lab
and now um million people are dying have
died
they'd be sued for a trillion dollars
now it's pretty clear
at least for most of the evidence that
i've seen that this virus has come
from a lab in muhat i don't think it's
it's a lot of evidence against the fact
there's none
against it there's a lot in favor of it
the wun lab is owned by the chinese
government
they're therefore responsible for
several trillion dollars of damages
uh what how do you actually go about to
go to the chinese government and say
why don't you pay for your damages
you know that that's that's above my pay
rate
um no i i look uh first of all i don't
think the case is proven
and in part because the science is so
politicized around this as around
everything else there are
there are a number of a lot of prominent
virologists who say that they believe
this is of natural origin they jump from
bats to you know some
seconds mammal species and then to the
to humans
that's why we need to investigate this
as to whether or not we're going to get
the chinese
assuming assuming we can ever
investigate it which is not clear
if you know do you think the chinese are
going to pay a dime for this i mean
good luck but but but we need to
investigate it
even if there will never be a political
consequence
or an economic consequence of the
chinese we need to investigate it
if for no other reason then that the
chinese are increasingly aggressive
around the world they're increasingly
powerful and they're increasingly
aggressive and if the world is afraid to
stand up to them
on this what is the lesson they're going
to take from it it's that even if
you know this did escape and believe me
they know where the virus came from at
this point
that that's for sure okay if if they if
they
are able to not even face a serious
independent
international inquiry on this what's the
lesson they're going to take
it's that they're so powerful they can
do whatever they want
and there will be no consequences and
that's a dangerous lesson again for all
of us
okay over here uh hi following up on the
question about
censorship uh and connecting it to
constitution day the constitution
presupposes not just
a virtuous people but a rational people
and it seems to me what's happened with
the covet virus is
brought into very stark relief the
question of whether
we're still all irrational people scott
adams the dilbert
cartoon creator says left and right are
watching different movies we have now
different conceptions of reality
i live in northwest dc in a liberal
neighborhood i can't even talk to my
neighbors anymore it's like their brains
have been taken over by aliens
um so my question is is this observation
true
it seems like some some substantial part
of the population
is no longer capable of rational thought
um do you agree with that
is is it permanent is it reversible is
it hopeless
okay who wants to take that well i'll
comment on that and
and there's a lot you could say about
that right but let me just say this you
know i mentioned that there's a survey
where
the average answer that americans gave
what percentage of our population has
died from covet average answer nine
percent
now just think about that if nine
percent of the people in this country
have died of
covid your relatives your friends your
neighbors your co-workers people who go
to your church they would all be
dropping like flies
right and and how how you can
how a person can simultaneously say well
i don't know anybody who's died from
covid none of my co-workers none of my
neighbors etc
but then when asked that question i
think nine percent of the population has
died
i don't know how anybody could possibly
um
believe that and and i think you know
there used to be such a thing as common
sense
you know and common sense is based on a
person's own experience
so if somebody came along and tried to
sell a line of bs
the average person would would test that
pro that proposition against his
experience and his
observation and he might say i don't
think so
that's not the way i've seen it that
hasn't been my experience it seems as if
that's just
gone you know so that now it's the guys
in the white coats you know now it's
headlines now it's something we heard on
cable news and there are many people who
seem to have
obtained this ability to internalize
those things without
checking it against their own common
sense which i think is very dangerous
so i i would just i would add one
thing which is people aren't very good
at math
i mean no they're not and and we should
teach
like statistics okay that's what should
be taught in high school forget
a past algebra forget anything you know
trigonometry statistics
are what people need to function in
society and so you know that nine
percent number i actually highlighted
that a couple of months ago but the
truth is people have no idea
they don't know how many people are in
the country and they don't know what
nine percent of the people
whose population they don't know is so
they just come up with a number
they know 30 million people didn't die
from covet they just don't know
they want they don't want to sound
stupid they don't want to pick a number
that's too low so they say nine percent
uh really but here there is
some hope okay which is there's a survey
done by something called the kaiser
family foundation
um you know certainly not a conservative
group uh
they've been studying they've been
asking people for a few months whether
or not
people think the worst of covet is
behind or ahead so in july
as you were having the sort of sun belt
spike um and the media was saying
there's going to be new yorks all over
the country
uh 60 of the country said uh the worst
was still ahead 20
said the worst was behind okay people
have actually paid attention the fact
that that didn't happen
um and so now the most recent uh survey
which was done last week
38 of the country thinks that kovid is
ahead
uh the worst is ahead and 38 percent
thinks it's behind
so some people are paying attention and
people who
you know the i i think the school's
reopening
uh first of all you know people are
going to be frustrated even some of
those urban knowledge workers are
frustrated with the fact that schools
are not properly open
but colleges you know college students
are zero risk
essentially zero risk from this and
they're under these
incredible idiotic and draconian
restrictions and tons of them are
getting positive tests and tons of them
are fine
and so that is seeping into parents and
it's seeping in
to you know the friends of those parents
and that's i mean that's many millions
of people
so i'm sort of hopeful that lived
experience is going to help people a
little bit
but it's been a slower process than
i would have liked yeah i mean
i mean your core concern is the correct
one the whole point of the public square
is to make sure everybody
has a little platform in that public
square in order for debate to lead to
truth
and debate doesn't lead to truth if you
keep half of the people out
and that's effectively what the
gatekeepers are doing so the the problem
is you no longer can find truth if you
search by google
you look at the great work of professor
epstein who
comes from the left he's a hillary
clinton backer and he identified that
even in 2016 google was able to at least
move millions of votes in the democratic
direction
just by manipulating the algorithm of
what search terms show up
and what as links show up when you do a
search and covet has been the ultimate
test case for how
governors will respond it used to be a
conspiracy theory
the idea that like an x-files show that
they're going to have a they're going to
declare an emergency and through an
emergency they're just going to suspend
the constitution and
at some point you'll even have camps for
people and now we have actually people
wanting to set up covet camps
in some parts of the country so this is
the kind of insanity that could only
occur
in a place where the public square has
been shut down and censored
and that's why it's a critical concern
that legislative action take place to
remedy it
thank you this has been uh an excellent
panel uh we could go on all morning but
actually we can't go on all morning uh
we'll have to uh
we'll have to call it there please join
me in thanking our panelists
thank you
you